okay last week we had to split this into
two because it was just too important
we didn't want to import we wanted to
take the time that it needed two of us
voted to just stop talking about this
but
matt gourley does all the editing and he
i guess has uh you know more power than
we do yeah and he uh outvoted us and
said no let's keep talking about james
bond arcana
yep
so this is a quiz on songs that were
done by popular musicians or bands that
were rejected as the james bond theme
songs that's a quick question sure
and this is from my own edification does
this mean that they a bunch of artists
were asked or did these artists
just blindly say
hey i think i have a good idea for
bonsang and they
they prepared it and they recorded it
and sent it in and it got rejected
because that would be humiliating i
think for the most part they were all
asked i believe johnny cash is the one
that did it unasked right yeah that's
amazing to
to be if you're a you know if you're a
huge group
huge singer huge star and you're asked
to do a bond song and then they they get
it and go eh yeah radiohead
because we've already covered that yeah
but i mean maybe they just sent in a
bunch of weird noises it is you know i
mean
i love radiohead but
quite a while ago they they started you
know yeah god bless them god bless him
yeah but they started you know uh
recording like uh an elevator engine and
then playing it backwards it's a little
uh it doesn't quite land
this one yeah because yeah they don't
kind of want you to it's like yeah you
either think this is cool you're dead to
us
okay let's get back into it murderer the
year is 2008 the film the much divisive
quantum of solace
very flawed script
well there's a writer strike but
otherwise yeah well then well
then what's that it's aging well is it
yeah
i watched it i didn't think it made
sense it doesn't but it's the whole
parts of it where they clearly don't
have script pages because there was a
writer's strike yeah and there's there's
a whole 10 minute sequence where you can
see daniel craig waiting for the next
page
[Laughter]
and then they hand it in on cameron he
quickly looks at it and he he makes his
nose wrinkles like he smelled something
bad and then he says i mean that's
terrible go back and look at it it's uh
it's 42 minutes in
i never saw it okay
here are your four options yep 2005 2008
eight yeah close you were only three
years off no okay and he just said it i
could do math coldplay
dame shirley bassey
the brian setzer orchestra
or sir paul mccartney sona yes
i'm just going to say shirley bass
that's correct oh good for you that was
great do that don't do that
i'm happy for you oh you got one right
oh my god that's nice you just
yeah what is it when you take the wind
out of your sails is that a thing is
that a saying that's what you just did
to me i was really excited and then you
ruined it for me
you're so happy i said good for you
now
we talked about this song because
whether or not this goes on this episode
or not but someone on this podcast
did a bond song and they uh that was
after the shirley bassy one was rejected
and it went to amy winehouse then jack
white and alicia keys yeah yeah okay
that's cool you can hear that one it's
good huh
okay can you imagine i mean i i i
you you and i
should work hard i'm not kidding
to get a bond song
i mean at least to write it i don't
they're not going to let me sing it
because it's going to take people out of
the movie like oh [ __ ] that's conan i
can tell it's him singing i wish he was
in the movie boo he's not and then the
movie's a flap first bond movie to flop
so
that that can't happen but i do think
you and i should write a bonsai i agree
it's just minor chords that's all you
got to do yeah a lot of e minors yeah a
lot of e minor in that original a minor
can you can you write one without
putting jokes in it like can you write a
sincere bond bond of course i could no
no i would just access my emotional core
we're going to be fine yeah and it's a
bond song some of them are just
ridiculous that's true
that's true if you've ever heard the
lyrics to the man with a golden gun
they're insane it's about like
like ejaculating is it really yeah yeah
he comes whenever he kills or does he
have a gun that shoots ejaculate
it works both ways every time i talk
like this you're like oh you're bringing
down the podcast oh no i just brought it
up i just hit it over hello i know the
difference yeah okay
so speaking of the man with the golden
gun
1974 man with golden gun yes
queen
alice cooper
meatloaf
or rod stewart
i'm going to go with rods conan rod
stewart that's incorrect okay i'm going
to just say queen because i love it
incorrect okay yeah and we're going to
do it again so
alice cooper or meatloaf what year is it
again 74.
alice cooper that's correct i was going
to say well you know what it's too early
to be eating no you didn't say well no
i'm just hold on i'm just saying you've
got to calm down sona it's it's uh it's
too early to meet loaf
meatloaf hasn't hit yet okay yeah but
you didn't answer it oh no so you all
your reasoning well these games i'm
sorry games are beneath me i'm i'm a
roman emperor watching all of you
scuttle in the uh because we're tied now
scuttle in the mud that's cause we're
tied now okay okay
so i'm out of options and we're tied
yeah
maybe what we could do
well you know what we could do because
it doesn't always have to be a winner i
mean either way i win
i mean i just went at life
um
that's not the point
the point is yeah
it was too early for meatloaf
it was 74 is way too early for meat love
um and i often think it's too early for
meatloaf
that's been one of my that's my motto in
life
if i could get one thing written on my
body it would be it's too early for
meatloaf
you know what someone's gonna come up to
me who's heard the podcast and go it's
too early for meatloaf
and i'm not gonna know what they're
talking about because i forget
everything after we're done here that's
the title of our bond song yes it's too
early
for meatloaf all right conan you just
won congratulations thank you i always
do i always do you've lost several times
uh we certainly lost listeners
we're bleeding we are bleeding listeners
we're hemorrhaging listeners
sorry about that we'll we'll get back on
track but that was informational